hey everyone i'm leanna glare with
Entertainment Tonight and I'm joined
right now by Katrina bells from
Outlander the two queens a jack and a
king Briana Clare Jamie and John Bell
whose name is lilian Union now we can
leave it like that
thank you so much for welcoming me into
the Willing well yes this is our tavern
where we spend much time Claire and I
have decided to try and make a life here
where will you settle we don't know yet
how are you describing season four the
Frasers come to America they are
immigrants it is about finding a home
and again it's very different to last
season in previous seasons so I think
people will be really excited about it
there'll be people here countries all
over the world all hoping to live what
would be called the American dream was
it fun for you to be able to shake it up
a little bit this year and get to
explore different pieces for Claire oh
my oh this season I love where the
costumes have gone to it's a real
frontier woman which is really cool
there's a lot of borrowed pieces which
is really nice you always like to play
with a little bit of a modern aesthetic
although tie it in to what's going on at
the time so that's quite cool Wender my
nephew is drawn to you we're gonna get
to see even more of Claire this year she
and Jamie are finally in the same place
at the same time yeah we we explore this
relationship in a different way this
season may request the pleasure of your
company for dinner we've done the
falling in love we've done the pining
we've done the reunion and you have to
try and explore different facets of the
relationship as you go forward you
really get to see this couple people to
enjoy each other's company you get to
see them in the Bliss of domesticity
they're really supporting each other
they're not on this cliffhanger of will
they won't they anymore it's very
different and it's it's a different to
sigh declare that we see it's much more
nurturing side of her so much
my friend you and I
having a home together peace of our own
you
[Music]